you don't know Bart cuz it obviously
you're the complete opposite and
personality wise but like just looking
at you you're like this guy's a [__]
psycho yeah he's a crazy freak psycho he
probably has no emotions or something
that's that it's like Tyler
[Music]
Perry and welcome back to another
amazing fantastic wonderful stupendous
episode of the careful boys damn
adjectives right there's a lot of
adjectives go today we are talking about
if you were setting up a dating profile
for yourself what would you lead with
we're all single right now yeah we're
single and we're lonely yeah lonely
single what would you lead with probably
do a shirtless picture of Bart on mine
yeah my face on it that's pretty good
would you keep your ears though oh but
you know what I have to leave with the
ears then are you trying to hook up or
you trying to like find love what are
you trying to
do oh it's up to us yeah Choose Your Own
Adventure how about hot and
horny okay if you're hot and horny what
what do you just write hot hot and horny
oh that's what you're Oh I thought you
were hot and horny no just right in the
caption super hot and horny what's the
photo look like
though
just nailed it that's somebody's cup of
tea I don't know I don't really know
what I would put on my thing like cuz
you know everything has to be like a
subtle Showcase of something you've got
offer you know what I mean it's like
your how about we pick everyone else's
okay yeah that's better cuz then you're
never going to say with [__] boxing
clubs on N dude I couldn't do that I
would honestly the first picture of you
would have you in your like fight wear
dude you want me to get zero cuz it's
like it shows who you are without saying
who you are but not pants though or like
one rolled up so you can show your sweet
tat oh you D I got to show the T off J I
would make you do that yeah and then the
first line would be like uh don't worry
I'm gentle and then the rest of your
[__] gay ass bio or just like in
middle school kids used to call me jumbo
yeah real talk though I think I have to
pass on that boy to just show yourself
like in your lifestyle yeah I like that
not like fake [__] like I'm in my
Lamborghini even if you have one I think
that's pretty tacky if you want to
attract those kind of girls but like if
you're into Jiu-Jitsu then it's like you
and your Jiu-Jitsu bu
or like if you're into people in the
first photo which one am I all photos or
like you're like you're like hiking cuz
that's what you do you like hiking you
know what I mean and then like yeah I
just think that then they can understand
it's like oh yeah you like this you like
this stuff I like this stuff too when
you're saying put it in your profile
you're talking about a sentence or
you're talking about a picture or all of
the above all but but picture picture is
the first thing like some people don't
even see what you typed because they're
just going looking at you and [__] M so
the first picture has to be a hook you
don't even read the bio until you click
on the picture so you you have to be at
least somewhat attracted before you even
see the bio so you got to really put
your best fo forward one thing that I've
seen guys do that are friends of mine
that are just like killing it on apps is
they are holding a [__] puppy oh dude
that's easy ba can you put a puppy in
mine then I want to be you think they're
just good-looking guys and the puppy
just enhances it well they are white oh
okay they do have ass
okay are the ABS showing with the pup
yeah oh dude that's that's too much
that's powerful bro I know that's a very
powerful picture my so my buddy who's
like just the freaking craziest at this
thing he that's his first picture
shirtless at the beach holding a puppy
RI and he's white his next photo he's in
a suit and he's at like Pebble Beach oh
yeah got to have a suit
on background exactly yeah he's at like
the concour delans the freaking let's
look at my tender yeah it's crazy let's
look at yours let's look at yours we'll
judge yours I haven't looked at it in
over a year so kid I feel like I would
like to put photos up that would attract
the type of girl I like cuz like you
know some guys would be like all right I
want to look like I'm a catch so I'm
going to have a herum of women around me
and I want to you know I'm I'm going be
flexing with my Rolex and my [__]
Ferrari because I want a 10 hot club
girl right but if your life isn't about
that and you really don't want a girl
like telling you let's go party every
night cuz you're just like I want to
stay home and play video games I think
you got to show you got to do the light
that you think that attracts those type
of girls it's kind of like if you want a
hot athletic surfer girl right like are
you a hot athletic Surfer boy and then I
don't think guys do that so what would
you put I would first like whatever time
of life I'm in I'd be thinking about
what kind of women I want m
like yeah if it's right now then it's
probably someone active someone that's
going to enjoy traveling someone you
know so then I'll think what would you
put for him ooh easy okay for him yeah I
got this too someone that likes to dance
what do you mean no what would you make
his profile look like like first picture
what's his photo his first photo in a
well you can't really show dance cuz un
photo but it'll be a pose of a dance
he's got a lot of photos where he's
showing dance idea but it might be bad
do it go for it what if we put Anthony
in blackace oh yeah it might get a lot
of tension on his profile I don't know
if a lot of ladies want to date that no
offense Anthony but I mean yeah it's
okay I also imagined Bart with a
murderous knife you know and a dead dog
in his hand so that's question with
dating profiles is do you want to like
Flex who you are cuz like a lot of you
guys have I think you have to flex a
little bit you know what I think it is
surprise it's Anthony Le on stage AG
ahead in the clouds and the cap says I'm
kind of a big deal like that bro I want
every photo to be with a celebrity it's
a picture of Anthony with Jackson Wayne
but Jackson Wayne's like in the front
and then Anthony's bar like
this it's him shoving Jackson Wing face
like that you want to know what's sadly
the most accurate thing that actually
makes the biggest difference showing
something that scales your height and
they can they can tell how tall you are
so me in a photo with all you [__]
hey man take that back that's [__] up
man no because that's the leading that's
the leading uh what's it Factor women or
but then we're talking about going for
volume then what if I do a fake one I do
a six feet like thing I'm like this
yeah yeah exactly yeah looking over it
yeah or it's like you're in a pool you
could see the six and your waist is up
you're just like like damn that guy 74
holy [__] yeah but I think if you're
being honest then choosing for each
other is pretty funny obviously you have
no shirt in yours in my dream I think
for M I would for sure lead with humor
to make sure just to make sure I attract
the right person that's all maybe I
would do blackface but I don't want get
canceled either
though that's leading with humor it's a
strong Choice mental illness to see like
how soft their like funny bone is yeah
with with bar out of his like five
photos that he has it's got to be the
last photo where he's just ripped yeah
yeah that's the [__] that be a the
finale what if you purposely go from
from ugly to fit oh you don't want to go
ugly to fit not
ugly it's like a ride how about get your
old photos when you're fat and then you
see the
transition or or every time you swipe
it's like he gets thinner and thinner
and thinner I think a dude dressed up
nice is a good first photo dude yeah
dress nice yeah warm clear clean maybe a
dog maybe height yeah at a wedding or
something you know oh that's cool
something like that that might be good
shows that you have family values you
know yeah you could take me to a wedding
you know I'll do a funeral one so I
don't I don't steal what you do yeah no
you we you could do it all baby you can
do it all almost like a nice head shot
you know what I mean a nice head shot I
don't think so I think mine mine has to
be something that doesn't make sense to
attract the person I like like I have to
maybe like wear a life
jacket while
like my face is covered in marshmallows
or something really something you don't
think people think you're scared
[Laughter]
cuz also look at you you know I think
very easily you could think this guy's
scary it's hard cuz women are they have
to be careful too and they you got
seconds to get their attention right
yeah yeah seconds cuz obviously we know
Bart so we know he's such a [__]
silly goose time but then when you see
him you're like this dude is scary as
hell it's like when I saw you if you
don't know B you don't if you don't cuz
it obviously you're the complete
opposite and personality wise but like
just looking at you you're like this
guy's a [__] psycho
yeah he's a crazy freak psycho he
probably has no emotions or something
that's that it's like Tyler
Perry yeah you're pretty intimidating at
first when people get to know you it's
like yeah he's a [__] idiot I mean
Terry Cruz not Tyler Perry I was like
that we both didn't say anything he said
he said tell
per I was like yeah media like media oh
yeah yeah yeah Terry
Cruz I haven't seen that
movie we just let him have it we're like
okay
when uh like I think like a decade ago
or whenever this was when I had a
serious tinner profile for like a short
bit I did do that I like had my craziest
photo of where how I look like my hair
and [__] and I got all like Goths and
rockabilly chicks and it was perfect but
I never went on one date oh really yeah
so how was it perfect because that was
exactly what I wanted to meet we like
that style of girls well why didn't you
go on Dat cuz I'm weird because I'm
weird and I went and I went I don't know
I don't think you know you get
wishy-washy and then you just don't do
it and I think that's what a lot of Happ
what happens to a lot of people on
dating apps because it's so like you get
so much volume you see so many different
people so it kind of feels like you met
a bunch of people but you really didn't
and you just go n [__] it plus I think
you just you just get more judgmental
you're just like H she doesn't seem like
she gets this humor you know like but
she might who knows you know you guys
want to judge my Tinder yeah all right
who want take it just hold it up hold it
up hold it up here I'll let Joe do it I
already like it oh that's good I already
like it what is that what are you
holding I think I'm he's not holding
nothing leaning on a ra collared shirt
he's wearing a collared shirt nice
spiffy that's a good picture of you this
way wait what does it say at the bottom
I think if you just tap oh oh that's
good I love hanging out with people who
go to concerts what music you listening
to that's a good ice breaker I like that
he's asking the person what they like is
this hinge and it feels real tender
tender this one looks like he's ready to
sell some Old Navy yeah also also PR
model it should be noted he was smiling
in the first picture which smiling is
good yeah that's a that's an important
thing yeah and and we can see his likes
okay he likes hiking I like the vines in
the back represents like a trail he
likes comedy music gamer and
dancing
oh it gets more undressed as we go you
got to take you got to take the top off
that's the be he's a YouTuber at
internet Missouri State University and
lives in
Torrance and look at that one wow what
is he listening to there's the camp rock
he has a
Spotify he has a Spotify so you know
he's an artist do you have the same
tastes oh okay what is it in the club
he's at the club at the club I don't
know what that picture is honestly he's
at the beach he's at the beach he's at
the beach he's at the beach guys glad at
the beach all right it's lock down it's
lock down stay safe during lock down he
he's
responsible look at that D watch out
some skin show a little nip you know got
a little Johnny Cage going on little
boxer this is more Zara than it is old
May there you go all right I am more
Zara than Old Navy in comparison to what
I used to be you active on that are you
hitting people up I haven't used it in
probably like a year or so you've been
on any actual dates did you ever follow
through with anything yeah I follow
through with I probably got on like 30
or 40 Tinder dates over ho [__] that
means you're just striking out all the
time or you just hooking up crushing bro
I so I would say the issue with Tinder
is pretty much every single person that
I've got on a date with I haven't shared
a single mutual friend with so so I
think that's usually what causes me to
not want to date them is because you
want to have mutual there's no one that
could vouch for them or just there's no
way you could like cross reference
what's going on like that it's just like
so much effort to try to like fully
integrate somebody into your life that
you have like no overlap that makes
sense and that's literally been 100% of
the dates I've gone on so it's usually
one and done when you go on these dates
no it'll usually be like a couple weeks
or so and then we'll just kind of like
run out of like unique things to do and
it'll be like you know we like each
other but not enough to like continue
putting in that energy and money and did
you use a dating app in Missouri yeah
and it even in Missouri you didn't meet
people with
mutuals not really wow most of the like
gay guys that I was attracted to were
usually guys that were coming from like
really far out in the sticks like really
yeah just like random like out from the
country from like the really small towns
really the only was it were they're like
the only gay guy there so they're like
but they're all buff because they're
like Lumberjacks yeah they're [__]
throwing ha [__] wearing nothing but
overalls in the forest chopping out
trees like none of them are buff I'm not
into buff guys okay did you have a sorry
Bart the buffest guy I know I know did
you have a type when you were like
looking through Tinder as as a swiper
yeah I have a type what's your what's
your type what what what are the first
things that would catch your eye not
just like a TI person yeah that's true
that's a good question is it the face is
it the dog think good looking
face face I like slim toned body types
face slim tone body no bellies what
about like captions or anything like
that what were were things that stuck
out that
worked I don't give a [__] about
captions I'm pretty
superficial how about aesthetic
aesthetic wise do you have any
preference if someone was more like
alternative or if they were more like
rockabilly yeah like a fashion honestly
I kind of prefer just like more
simplistic down to earth
just more into like nature and the world
than they are
into what would be like a turn off
Patagonia um L not into like too much
jewelry or piercings yeah right answer
right for jewelry dude yeah I think my
jewelry like limit is like one thing so
like you either have your ears pierced
or you're wearing a necklace or you have
like like one thing and then that's like
you get a guy with bangal disqualify
buddy you don't got that much bling on
you that's cool I got more than one
don't look don't look country boy though
like literally playing in the woods for
like the first like 15 years of my life
so I just so I just like down toe [__]
honestly like I'm just basic that sounds
really fun I'm trying to become like
more into consumerism and stuff cuz I
know that's what most people care about
but it's boring compar comparatively
which do you prefer the your uh the
dating app when you're using it here or
when you're in
Missouri um probably here cuz there's
literally a thousand times more people
oh oh way more diverse like people that
you meet and stuff yeah but but I do
think I was like I've noticed strangely
enough I think in general I'm more
attracted to people in Missouri than in
California and maybe that's just because
what I was risen around could be
personality too honestly that's that's
possible yeah cuz big cities just don't
lead to like long-term anything or in
like deeper anything just in general
it's more like hookup culture and like I
just feel like it's more
superficial cuz you have so many options
you could [__] all day and people are
more disposable out here it's not 31
Flavors it's 31,000 flavors which one
you want yep it's unlimited just kidding
news careful boys is a brand just
kidding news is the man of smart people
the people of just kidding news careful
boys they are very smart just kidding
news the number one podcast in the
[Music]
world
I